yeah can you hold on one second I just
got a I got to unfold my phone real
quick weird flex but okay
[Music]
I feel like every week we get a new
rumor that the Samsung Galaxy fold is
about to relaunch like it's coming soon
it's passed the tests they finished the
redesign it's about to launch again it's
finally ready like at this point I'll
believe it when I see it but until then
since the fold never is officially
launched and Huawei's going through some
things this is the first and only
folding phone to actually ship in 2019
this is it this is the Royal flex pie so
I've taken a closer look at it
technically we saw it briefly at CES in
January but that was barely hands-on
like they let us see it and take videos
of it but every five seconds they take
it out of our hands and show us how to
use it correctly so I feel like that
barely qualified as a hands-on which
like I get it that's your first way of
showing the world what you've done but
now that I've got it in a studio with no
employees around me I get to treat it
like I treat every other phone that
comes through here
normally so the unboxing is pretty solid
kind of janky with the amount of poor
translation happening in the box but
that's not what I'm judging it came with
a few accessories in there which is nice
but I'm judging the phone here and my
first impression just of actually
holding the phone for the first time is
it's it's really weird looking but I'll
get more into that in a sec really the
main thing to consider here is there's a
couple different ways to do a folding
phone there's the way that folds out
with the screen on the inside and then
there's the way to fold out with the
screen on the outside and the bottom
line from what I'm getting with the Flex
PI is the folding screen on the outside
is not the way to go so first of all
like we knew already the flexible OLED
panel which is the most delicate part is
exposed to the elements all the time
it's not covered it's also thicker
because the components can't really
completely fold flat onto each other and
unlike folding a piece of paper the
radius of this fold is still way greater
than 0 it's much more of like a sharp
curve than a fold honestly and so the
whole thing becomes too chunky to
reasonably fit in most people's pockets
it's like kind of like the size of the
Seinfeld wallet honestly your money now
you know what maybe I can't judge the
whole concept on this super early hard
like so many pieces of this feel just
like a hack like look at this hinge the
most vulnerable important part that
isn't the screen the hinge
it's literally covered in this like
accordion shaped rubber and then screwed
in on the sides it isn't smooth to fold
and unfold it kind of makes some noises
sometimes when you touch it the wrong
way while folding and I just have my
doubts about this material not wearing
down over time with lots of folds and
being in the Sun and getting scratched
and maybe even ripping I mean I guess
technically the rubber on the back here
is preventing debris from getting into
the hinge and then maybe popping up
under the screens so that's their
solution around that but now your phone
looks like an accordion also I don't
think there's any number of folds that
this mechanism is rated for like the
Galaxy fold which had that highly
engineered hinge we all saw the video
where they claimed two hundred thousand
folds by a robot and you know we saw how
that went but this is not giving me the
impression that it's more durable than
that really feels like a hack oh and
then there's the crease so there were
plenty of thoughts on the galaxy folds
very slight crease from folding in the
royal flex pie because of the way it
folds out has two creases you can kind
of see them like one on either side of
this hinge they try to play like you
have three screens one front one back
and one side like they really told me
that at CES that this is a three screen
phone and it's got this kind of awkward
sliding shortcut UI in the middle on
this third screen that's not what I
would call a third screen but you know
with any folding phone they're trying to
make features that take advantage of
this new form factor they've ended up
with and with this water OS on the Royal
flex PI you know there's a couple
there's not many for example you can
turn on or off the back screen at any
time if you want with a button that's
permanently in the navigation bar the
front and back screen are also treated
like two different user interfaces by
remembering the state of your use
separately so if I'm on one screen and I
open the Settings app and I flip it over
and on that screen I open up the clock
when I flip back to the other side the
settings
still open and when I go back to the
other side the clock is still open as
well so I could see that separate use
being somewhat useful if I get used to
it
kind of like how the Galaxy fold treated
the front and back screen as separate
most of the time different wallpaper a
different app layout the whole thing and
then because of the dual camera layout
you can have the front and back of the
phone show as a viewfinder while you're
taking a photo
so the selfies shot with the main camera
can be you know a higher quality and
then people you're taking a photo of
will see themselves in the back screen
and probably look at that instead of the
camera lens and if you scroll far enough
in the camera settings there's something
called baby mode which replaces that
back screen with some entertaining
cartoons and characters to get your baby
to I guess look at the phone when you
take pictures of them nice so that's
cool I guess but what this layout has
really taught me is if you want to take
photos of something out there with the
full viewfinder you can't there's no
cameras on the back they're all facing
you so you can't take photos of things
that aren't you unless you close the
phone I think my favorite quirk though
is that almost every version of
auto-rotate almost every version works
ready so this works this doesn't work
this works and this works and then you
fold it you get this to work this works
this doesn't work then this does same
thing on the other side I don't know why
it was so fascinating to me that you
have like 16 ways to rotate it and like
14 of them work look this is a super
early folding phone and this is what
you're gonna get when you've rushed to
be first mission technically
accomplished you're first but at what
cost has it gotten better since CES
actually yes especially in the
animations Department I still wouldn't
call it fluid by any means that's not a
word I would use but it's at least
smoother than it was a few months ago
but no matter how you move around this
form-factor
grabbing the screen from both sides and
folding it in half at least on this
phone is incredibly awkward also things
like the volume buttons being split
above and below the fingerprint reader
which is also not
our button that doesn't help the lack of
headphone jack doesn't help the noises
you get sometimes when you fold it that
doesn't help and of course water OS not
having much English in it no Google Play
services no Play Store that didn't help
either I'm not trying to put my sim card
in this phone and use it every day and
have my information sent to
who-knows-where
I guess importing this phone was a bit
of a hack in the first place and all
that is not to mention the battery
concerns when I first boot it up this
phone I got a little bit of a walk
through and part of that walk through
said only to charge it while it's
unfolded I I literally have no idea why
bottom line this phone actually just
really makes me miss the galaxy fold
like I already missed it when I had to
give it back but this really doubled
those feelings now don't get me wrong
the flex PI has flashes of brilliance
like sometimes I just look at it in my
hands and it's wild that you you have a
screen folded over backwards and still
working perfectly and responsive and not
broken
like that's already amazing I feel like
you could show this to someone from five
years ago and they'd be very impressed
and surprised but it also makes you
think what will these look like in five
more years from today okay I've learned
two main things from playing with this
phone one being first doesn't really
matter if it sucks like and that applies
to a lot of other things but especially
with new tech and with this folding
phone but then to folding in is better
than folding out like folding out is
cool and it looks potentially better
that Huawei mate X that we've been
drooling over because it seems to look
so much better than the Galaxy fold I
think it will look better but I don't
think that's the way to use a folding
phone I think as long as the screens and
the hinges are as shaky and not so
durable as they are now folding in is
gonna be the better way also don't
forget about that Motorola RAZR that's
gonna sort of fold in if that ever
happens I think that's another good way
to do it but the whole folding out thing
probably not the way to go either way
that's been it thanks for watching got
you guys the next one taste